bonjour à tous voici ce que vous devez
savoir ce lundi 3 décembre c'est le jour
j pour david saint-jacques leçon autres
canadiens s'envolera vers la station
spatiale internationale dans une heure à
6h30 et une très exactement heure de
l'est
il sera accompagné de ses deux
coéquipiers le commandant russe et
l'américaine
le ministre des finances eric girard
dépose à midi le premier annoncé
économique du gouvernement de la cac et
la 24ème conférence mondiale sur le
climat s'est ouverte en pologne
en l'absence de la plupart des chefs
d'état et de gouvernement on voit tout
de suite allé retrouver notre
correspondante à marc altérer ce cookie
et à baïkonour au kazakhstan pendant
qu'on voit ces images du canadien qui
saluent son fils à un de ses enfants et
son épouse il y à quelques quelques-uns
alors tamara donc vous êtes vous avez eu
la chance de voir les installations hier
de faire le tour d'assister à la
bénédiction
décrivez moi un peu l'atmosphère qui
doit régner autour du parti est d'abord
diffusé vers l'est pas mais on peut
passer à l'atelier pionnière de
l'exploration face à l équipe on va
envoyer les produits satellites dans les
années 50 la première fusée et il n'ya
pas sur ye qui a changé on ne gagne et
traction absolument délicieuse dans les
commentaires et tricot exprime faire
couper les cheveux ils ont vu trinqué au
champagne tout le monde à part d'écouté
un film que nous faisons le même depuis
les années 50 on commence à l'époque de
l'urss et ce matin c'est pas des farces
la tradition veut c'est parce que
gagarine l'avait fait en 1961 pour le
premier vol d'une tonne humaine à
l'espace usines et sur la roue qui du
camion qui les amène jusqu'au jusqu'au
jusqu'à la crise et donc c'est comme ça
à chaque étape depuis trois jours pour
cette grande et par des traditions
beaucoup de superstition je voudrais que
ça ajoute un certain stade
lancement on en a vu des centaines et
des centaines celui-là est exceptionnel
c'est pourquoi pour nous le canada parce
qu'il ya des saint-jacques et à bord
mais si le premier lancement habité donc
le premier vol habité depuis cet
accident qui aurait pu être très très
très grave
au mois d'octobre c'est assez incroyable
de voir qu'on se livre comme vous et à
des débats des moments de superstition
comme cela et qu'on va envoyer trois
personnes dans une station spatiale
qu'on a corrigé le pépin qu'on avait au
mois d'octobre
c'est assez invraisemblable toi quand
ils apportent toujours car il
la cloche sonne la porte du hangar se
lève on la tire en locomotive et km de
voies ferrées de compote ou pâtiront la
dref et quand la voix sept suivantes
rend compte qu'elles vont plutôt que de
changer avec les animait les
collectivement que tu es quand on voit
cette capsule david saint jacques et ses
coéquipiers sont déjà assises depuis
deux bonnes heures s'est fait tout petit
attendu pour eux parce que aujourd'hui
le vol était exceptionnel de ce rendez
vous ce matin dès 6 heures c'est à dire
que six heures exactement après le
décollage
ils y auront rendez-vous de pater avec
la station spatiale internationale ils
vont faire trois fois pendant quatre
fois le tour de la terre pour avant
damart et donc au millimètre de vous
êtes le matin les aumôneries quand il
lui sera fini à montréal on aurait eu la
chance de voir la fuel amarrée à la
station spatiale internationale on
pourra voir l'ouverture de la capsule
est d'avis que nous sommes entrés dans
l'habitation humaine applis sur terre un
premier appel à tata c'est
extraordinaire tabac là j'ai jamais eu
la chance de voir décoller
julie payette parce qu'à chaque fois
qu'elle a fait la dernière tentative là
ils étaient dix étaient y était il y
avait une
j'avais un orage avait du mauvais temps
est ce que la météo joue on dirait juin
- grand rôle dans la veille aux qu'avec
les navettes américaines non policy on
nous a dit qu'on me colle est beau temps
mauvais temps qui est extrêmement froid
vous plein coeur du kazakhstan dont
contador
il y fait un temps superbe été le cas
comme ça depuis qu'on dit depuis trois
jours il ya plus mariage expire à la
scène encore poubelles doivent décoller
comment cette couche et l'est toujours
une petite couche rose qui colore le
cerneau ça risque d'être un des
collègues magnifique et puisque vous
parlez de vie fayette élite ici on a pu
la voir tout ça là c'est un peu la scène
parce que cet égard on voit jamais les
coulisses et la pluie que la famille
reçoit beauvaisis payet qui grande amie
de la famille parce que si elle se
divise et de gouvernance en général et
aussi d'extras prenant mais un épaule la
famille pour cette journée cruciale et
tout à l'heure quand on était dans la
pièce qu'ils ont séparés par une fenêtre
visite où on voyait les astronautes
enfiler leur combinaison spatiale vers
lui ça y est tu étais là être des
enfants à leur expliquer la suite des
choses dans celle est quelque chose de
très mignon d'après système de succès
chez les astronautes et puis qu'on écrit
la famille mais jamais jamais seul etc
on aurait pu penser que les enfants qui
sont 13e pour garder par des nanas
gardel il énonce un en téléphonant dans
ma tête ce qu'est qui étaient là qui est
parti de la fouillouse et qui a passé
six mois dans les pattes une année de
bep score pour la famille cantin d'ici
10 ans ils sont tous très proches l'un
de l'autre c'est beau à voir
d'un côté l'extorsion pascal convoi
d'annette parce que les sacrifices qui
est d'avis qu'un accès c'est quand même
assez exceptionnel de patrimoine
il est des enfants très jeune âge c'est
adorable de les voir c'est triste de les
voir avoir hâte de voir comment faire
alors faire comme ça pour une mission de
6 mois ni mais je sais que la fierté je
suis enfant de ces garçons l'emportent
heureux pour la crise test mais une qui
répond avoir quelques conversations les
anecdotes à raconter
vous savez les vendredis quand on dit on
montre à la place ce qu'on a fait
on va diriger par l'ap après il était
dans la station spatiale mardi c'est moi
peut-être qu'on pense
il est fourni autour du filet de voir la
vie la vie continue ouais ouais ouais
quand on a 80 ou au 6 allée au chocolat
passe avant un lancement de navette
alors c'est comme ça mais bon je sais
que ça va être difficile de vous parler
à cause de toutes les contraintes
techniques mais écoutez on reste à
l'affût
et puis pour parler ça va dépendre de
l'acte et qui nous donne d'habitude
une demi heure avant le décollage mais
il devient après mon va tout faire pour
merci beaucoup tamara je vous disais il
ya un instant je n'ai pas eu la chance
de voir décoller julie payette un
raisonnement des états membres leur
c'est lui qui est allé la voir décoller
david gentilles et qui est allé au bras
de juillet c'était en juillet en 2009
j'étais lent juin rien que fonctionnaire
il y avait les nuages la grosseur d'un
médecin sous je crois et puis la navette
peut pas partir mais vous vous êtes
arrivé au bon moment et vous êtes aussi
un ami de david saint jean vous avez bon
vous vous vous vivez ça aussi d'une
certaine façon au niveau personnel ce
départ
absolument ce qui est assez formidable
c'est qu'effectivement en 2009 fera du
canada va envoyer en fleuret de couvrir
le décollage de julie payette et
quelques semaines avant d'enlever de
saint jean qui est un ami d'enfance à -
avait été nommé comme futur astronaute
donc on a assisté au décollage de julie
payette ensemble c'est un événement
absolument formidable et un hasard
absolument incroyable parce que moi je
connais david saint-jacques de fiction
en secondaire 2 et ça a été mon
colocataire
et à québec pendant qu'elle faisait ses
études de médecine donc un concours de
hasards qui nous mêmes ici aujourd'hui
moi j'ai l'impression que comme une
forme de destiner dans le cas de david
qui a ces jeunes n'avaient énoncé
verbaliser sa volonté de devenir
astronaute
bon vous l'avez connu donc de puits
secondaires de avait toujours eu
l'impression que kiki qui était destiné
à faire ces choses-là près tous y
détient seulement trois grands diplômes
professionnels génie astrophysique et
médecine et parle cinq langues
alors à part ça ça va bien je vais
rencontrer david saint jacques en
secondaire 2 est en train de construire
une planche à voile c'est vous que c'est
vraiment un ingénieur années j'ai été
avec lui à l'école secondaire d'ailleurs
je le remercie de m'aider à passer
quelques examens de physique et de
mathématiques
par la suite il a poursuivi ses études
et c'est être un éternel premier davet
de séracs non plus d'être très talentueu
et c'est extrêmement travaillant et sa
plus grande qualité je pense c'est qu'il
a l'humilité des gens pour qui
l'apprentissage est une seconde nature
donc lorsqu'il n'est pas excellent dans
un domaine des affaires et c'est pour ça
qu'ils s'améliorent constamment comme ça
avec le temps effectivement le vus faire
son parcours académique il faisait un
post doctorat au japon imaginer race qui
m'a appelé un jour pour me dire je veux
revenir aux études j'ai le goût d'aller
en médecine dont je l'étais coûte 31
autres camps spector était à l'école
assez longtemps mais il m'avait dit à ce
moment alain vers 2001 non j'aimerais
faire quelque chose pour rien et des
plus concrètement les gens et c'est à ce
moment là que je les ai vus mois pendant
deux ans entre trois ans commencé ses
études en médecine avec des gens qui
avaient 10 ans de moins que lui toujours
très travaillant très studieux et
passionnés par ce qu'ils faisaient donc
c'est véritablement une joie pour moi de
le voir s'envoler et c'est pas tout à
fait étonnant parce que je dois dire
qu'en secondaire 5
lorsqu'on énonçait ses choix de carrière
c'était déjà quelqu'un de très
particulier
il nous avait dit il faut peut-être
pilote de chasse peut-être à son
physique
peut-être pourquoi pas astronautes et
moi je me souviens qu'on avait même pas
rigoler tellement c'était un homme de
talent dont il n'est pas devenu pilote
de chasse mais il sait piloter
il est astrophysicien et aujourd'hui va
s'envoler donc c'est formidable de voir
le parcours de cet homme là qui est un
grand talent un qui est aussi un très
bon ami et je dois dire oui
des anecdotes particulier qu'avec que
vous retenez le charbon comme ça des
moments qui vous ont fait qu'ils ont
fait rire aucune vision fait pleurer bah
écoutez moi je pense que le moment qui
m'a le plus marqué qui parle le plus de
ce qu'ils avaient de saint jacques
c'est justement leur style et lorsqu'il
a débuté ses études de médecine à 31 ans
c'était mon colocataire l on parle d'un
gars quand même relativement doux et je
me souviens de son esprit les premières
semaines quand il s'est rendu compte que
ça allait être assez difficile quand
même et là il m'a dit écoute je suis
obligé de travailler fort donc il passa
de pouvoir est véritablement à étudier
comme cela et pour lui coûter c'était un
effort de se rendre compte qu'ils
avaient mémorisé des briques comme ça de
matériel mais il l'a fait encore une
fois avec beaucoup d'aplomb toujours
très studieux et beaucoup d'humilité je
pense que c'est ce qui distingue avait
deux sergents de la plupart des gens non
seulement il est très talentueux mais en
plus de ça c'est quelqu'un qui est
toujours l'humilité de vouloir apprendre
et qui s'intéresse beaucoup aux gens aux
humains et je pense que c'est ce qui va
marquer justement sont le sens de sa
mission dans l'espace
et c'est ingrat également qui se déplace
pour fêter votre anniversaire de
naissance aussi alors ça aussi ça je l'
ai vu de mes yeux alors avec tout un
calendrier comme le siea lancé c'est pas
mal je pense qu en dit long aussi sur
l'amitié qui le joue pas alors on va
l'écouter rester là profiter pleinement
de ce moment là avec avec les membres de
la famille et vos amis tout auto merci
donc vous voyez les premières images qui
nous parviennent du cosmodrome baïkonour
haut doubs sera lancé la fusée le
lanceur soyouz à 6h30 et urnes alors je
vous dis que charles tisseyre qui
s'avance tranquillement vers moi sera
avec nous pour nous en parler tout au
cours de cette expérience
[Musique]
assez tôt mais parce que je suis
vraiment prêt dans l'espace et passe on
n'est jamais prêt à ce sont des images
de notre astronaute canadien david saint
jacques l'écuyer au moment où ils
étaient choisis et qui se préparait et
vous voyez toutes sortes d'imagés on va
retrouver tout de suite tamar altérer ce
cookie et à baïkonour au kazakhstan où a
lieu le lancement
parce qu'on voit des images en boucle
des images de du lettrage en anglais on
envoie en russe en cyrillique également
parce que c'est tout un entraînement 9
ans d'entraînement pour en arriver là
tamara à akwa à 45 minutes ou à peu près
là en fait c'est très exactement du
décollage alors tu aimeras tout va bien
tout est tout étant dans l'ordre à
baïkonour
oui et je comptais de pouvoir vous
trouvez une vous montrer un peu où
est-ce qu'on est oui c'est ce que je
vous disais tout à l'heure on est
vraiment on est vraiment dans un champ
dans les steppes du kazakhstan à un
mille derrière moi je sais pas si vous
la voyez rip petit la fusée soyouz
david saint-jacques ses coéquipiers
l'américaine est l'heureuse donc sont là
depuis déjà 2 heures et c'est assez
important on est on formate leurs sièges
avant de les faire monter on les
transporte immédiatement après dans la
fusée à titre d'ingénieur de bord c'est
avec ce genre qui est entré le premier
ensuite dans le milieu oleg le capitaine
russe et admettent lane pour qui ça sera
aussi un baptême de l'espace donc la
fusée elle est là bas nous on est à un
mail exactement et il ya la famille
il est par la famille seulement de david
singer des américains des russes les
enfants sont là la gouverneure générale
est ici les agences spatiales des
différents pays qui sont représentés ici
pour qui c'est l'aboutissement d'un
projet énorme dont les américains en
bois des astronautes beaucoup plus
souvent que le canada pour le canada
c'est le sixième lancement
c'est le premier lancement en six ans
donc il ya vraiment une une fébrilité
chez les canadiens qu'on voit peut-être
pas chez les américains et les russes
pour les russes les soyouz on en lance
assez souvent les cosmonautes russes on
en croise souvent plusieurs par année et
pour le canada on sent vraiment quelque
chose d'extraordinaire qui se passe ici
c'est un événement rare et c'est un
événement
le décollage c'est la partie la plus
risquée la plus dangereuse la plus
intense de cette mission qui
rappelez-vous va faire six mois et demi
ce sera la mission la plus longue pour
le canadien dans la station spatiale
internationale dont on a hâte de voir
cette fusée s'envoler vers le ciel vous
voyez le soleil commence à baisser ici
c'est vrai de magnifiques on devra en
plusieurs couleurs dans le ciel au
moment où la fouille se doit décoller
vous disiez 7 à 6 heures 31 précisément
mais pour être vraiment précise
marc-andré ces six heures 31 58 secondes
alors c'est pas pareil ne pas changer
passe contrée bois n'ont fait pas pareil
on prévoit un amarrage six heures plus
tard mais c'est des choses qui se
travaille depuis des années on a tout ce
qu'il faut donc les étoiles sont
vraiment alignés pour que la suze puisse
avoir un rendez vous spatial dans six
heures exactement avec mais après le
décollage avec la station spatiale
internationale
le même jour et c'est rare qu'on a
l'occasion de voir ça on pourra d'ici ce
soir heure de montréal bien sûr voir
david saint jacques
arrivé à la station spatiale
internationale et y est entrée et même
communiqué probablement si tout se passe
comme prévu
premier contact avec la terre bon ben
j'ai apprécié la précision donc on
s'inquiétera pas 6h31 58
c'est à ce moment là qu'on verra le
décalage de zeeuw merci beaucoup et on
verra à la prochaine je vous en prie
avoir quelque chose quand même de la
retrouver comme ça à un mille du pas de
tir tamar altérer ce que notre
correspondant en russie on va retrouver
des tâches antilles c'est l'animateur de
l'émission découverte qui est avec nous
ce matin pour suivre ça bonjour on
nettoie votre premier lancement
on avait vu en personne ou un geste au
départ de roberta bondar sur avery
j'étais sur le toit de nbc à cinq
kilomètres du pas de tir et j'ai pu
assister au décollage d'une navette
spatiale est très impressionnant jette
avec steve maclean chritian quand elle
relevé tu veux te lèves et tu prends pas
t'empêcher de te lever midi cramponne
toi l'athabasca un nom de chaque va
arriver elle va te projeté par terre et
sgp a été projeté par terre parce que
j'ai écouté conseil de steve je me
tenais comme ça et effectivement avec le
mur de molécules qui t'arrive
suite à cette explosion contrôlée qui
est un décollage de la navette spatiale
ou de fusée soyouz
tintin mur comme ça qui s'en vient il
faut que tu te rends pon alors c'est sûr
que la navette spatiale était une
puissance absolument étonnante plus
puissantes au décollage que le seuil aux
sourires on dit que la navette spatiale
en est pas qu aurait pu éclairer l'état
de new york au complet au décollage ça
va à peu près la puissance d'un cette
chance un coude et au décollage la
skieuse est moins puissante mais c'est
un véhicule extraordinaire c'est la
fusée qui a eu le plus le meilleur taux
de succès jusqu'à maintenant
en ce qui concerne les risques que
prennent des instruments de même s'il ya
eu cet incident mode octobre c'est
considéré comme une fusée très très
sécuritaire et c'est un risque mais mes
calculs et parce que la preuve c'est
qu'ils sont revenus sur terre
eden les deux les deux cosmonautes qui
étaient à bord de l'appareil à son
malheur c'est ce qui est vraiment
remarquable avec le studio c'est cette
capacité de sauver les astronautes dans
des études dans des situations extrêmes
ce qui est arrivé aux soyouz de rose
octobre ressemble à ce qui t'arrive à
challenger c'est à dire que c'est les
fusées d'appoint
c'est une fusée d'appoint propulseurs
d'appoint du soyouz qui a eu une
défaillance et qui a atteint le
réservoir de la fusée centrale mais
c'est ce qui est arrivé à challenge est
dans le camp de challengers tous les
astronautes sont morts et dans le cas de
soyouz ils sont revenus parce que c'est
prévu comme ça la capsule se sépare de
la fusée et revient en parachute par la
suite et tout au long de l'ascension
aujourd'hui
cette possibilité là demeure c'est ce
qui est extraordinaire avec le studio
c'est le véhicule le plus sécuritaire
même si c'est pas comme mir ali dans son
salon non non non on comprend ça et et
ont maintenant on en a parlé dont vous
ai compris peau question d'énerver
personne est de faire du
sensationnalisme
on s'entraîne pour cela les russes les
américains les européens les japonais
tout le monde travaille là dessus pour
que ce soit un tel succès mais on se dit
neuf ans de préparation
c'est considérable s'est exprimé
ça prend plusieurs années pour former un
astronaute bien sûr que dans le cas des
astronautes canadiens puisque on
participe à moins de 3% au budget de la
station spatiale on ne vole pas souvent
et donc david a dû attendre plusieurs
années de plus que s'il avait été un
astronaute américain
et pendant ce temps là il s'est formé
extraordinairement pour celui sur la non
il est 5 h 52
donc l'appareil va s'élancer là on va
lancer ce 6e cette fusée à 6h30 yeux des
58 c'est à nous habiller précisé
maintenant que font-ils ils sont bien
assis dans leur dans la capsule
qu'est ce qu'ils doivent faire comme
comme étape les vérifications je présume
d'usagé pour les vérifications pour
s'assurer que tous les systèmes du
soyouz fonctionne tel que prévu ils font
ça en tandem avec le centre de contrôle
des tests de pressurisation pour
s'assurer que tout est étanche et bien
sûr tout ce qui concerne le
fonctionnement de l'appareil juste avant
le décollage et pendant le décollage le
décollage a duré 9 minutes
il ya plusieurs phases différentes et
donc il faut se préparer à tout cela et
c'est ce qu'ils sont en train de faire
en ce moment ça dure environ deux heures
et demie cette préparation finale avant
avant dit
quand je regarde et on les verra tout à
l'heure parce qu'on aura certainement
cette image de la caméra où on les voit
entassés je veux dire ils n'ont pas
besoin de se tirer le bras pour toucher
aux voisins ils sont véritablement le
céou cm qu'ils sont installés dans la
capsule
oui on est très très serré dans la
partie pilotable si je puis dire je suis
use parce que c'est un véhicule qui a
été conçu à la fin des années 50 et
durant les années 60 par le grand corps
lève qui est le vent de brown du
programme spatial soviétique à l'époque
et c'était pas conçu pour transporter
autant de monde dans un confort absolu
par contre ce qui est extraordinaire
c'est que la partie qui est qui pis la
table si je puis dire et surplombé par
une sphère qui elle est le module habité
ou habitable et ils peuvent communiquer
entre les deux sections
donc c'est vrai qu'ils sont très très
serré wen au décollage ou l'atterrissage
mais une fois qu'ils sont en orbite
ils peuvent effectivement aller dans la
partie qui est un peu plus large en
rouille a pas de siège et des sacs de
couchage il ya même de l'eau et même une
toilette
alors ça c'est quelque chose qui
existait déjà dans les années 60 les
américains n'avaient pas ça des
américains ils allaient dans l'espace
d'abord dans une capsule mercury vous
était très serré une capsule de gemini
où ils étaient 2 deux astronautes mais
très serré et même la capsule apollo
n'avait pas offert cette possibilité là
de d'avoir une espèce de petite station
spatiale déjà c'est vrai que souvent il
y avait deux modules habitables parce
que la capsule devra faire quelques
rotations quelques heures bête avant
d'arriver parce que c'est pas au monde
directement et on est roi a marre et non
et il ya quelques rotations vendit
arrivé à la station spatiale
il ya deux il ya deux scénarios le
scénario rapide 4 repassions orbite
chaque orbite prend une heure et demi
donc six heures pour atteindre la
station spatiale internationale
ça c'est si ils réussissent à atteindre
leurs beats nominal qu'il vise
aujourd'hui tout indique c devrait se
produire son problème
il n'y arrive pas c'est la fusée un
petit peu moins de puissance que prévu
si l'angle l'angle d'entrer dans leur
[ __ ] un peu différent mais niveau ils
vont devoir prendre le scénario l'on est
selon la qui prend un peu plus de deux
jours pour rejoindre la station spatiale
internationale
et là c'est 34 orbite qu'ils devront
faire mais ça c'est quelque chose que le
soyouz a toujours fait pendant des
années des années avant de que l'on
modifie s'il ya seulement je pense deux
ou trois ans le scénario pour avoir un
scénario court et pour avoir le scénario
course est simple il faut que la station
spatiale internationale passe au dessus
de baïkonour
et si on décolle tout de suite après là
on peut avoir le scénario court mais si
si la station spatiale internationale
devait passer non pas directement au
dessus d'un coup nous remet un peu à
côté
mais tant que le lancement soit retardée
par exemple ils peuvent quand même
atteindre la station spatiale
internationale mais ils doivent prendre
à ce moment là le scénario long c'est
absolument essentiel parce que c'est
pratiquement comme 2-2 très gros caillou
qu'on fait tourner autour de la terre et
qu'on doit un peu tentés de d'aligner le
pascaa pas c'est pas un bimoteur look on
est senior non c'est pas comme ça que ça
se déplace poursuivant c'est le sioux
marsa et je peux vous dire que les
américains et les russes dans les années
60 ont pris beaucoup de temps pour
maîtriser cette technique la du rendez
vous il ya il a fallu d'abord démontré
qu'on pouvait le faire avec des capsules
gemini pour ceux qui ont vu le film le
premier ramon se rend compte que quand
ils ont réussi à faire cet amarrage
laconi rammstein a réussi à faire
l'amarrage avec la section de fusil qui
avait été prévu pour ça ça a été
compliqué ça a été difficile et cd
calcul très complexe qui ont dû être
faits à la mitaine dans les années 60
maintenant ça se fait automatiquement
par au fond les ordinateurs de bord on
ne sait pas exactement le soyouz va se
trouver quand il va être synthétisés
donc c'est un peu ça qui est un peu
incertain alors le centre de contrôle
est capable de savoir quand il est
utilisé exactement où se trouvent deux
soyouz
ils suivent continuellement la station
spatiale internationale ils savent
toujours où elle est et quand ils ont
exactement ces deux positions là là ils
peuvent envoyer aux soyouz à
l'ordinateur de bord du
use le plan d' attaque on rejoindre la
station spatiale internationale
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que là
qu'on leur donne des données actives et
tel bouton pour tel angle change un peu
l'anglais ralentir et accélérer pour en
arriver à un arrimage partie si
l'ordinateur de bord qui fait
automatiquement mais si l'ordinateur ne
peut pas le faire à ce moment-là les
astronautes peuvent le faire
manuellement sont parfaitement entraînés
pour ça ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est
que la station était au delà de 400 km
de la terre donc il tourne à une
certaine vitesse du vent je suis aux 8 à
peu près 200 km de la terre comme un
stud donc et tourner plus rapidement que
la station spatiale tout ce qu'il a à
faire au fond c'est changer d'orbité
tranquillement mais rester serein orbite
plus serré pour rattraper éventuellement
la station spatiale internationale qui
elle va plus lentement
donc si la cible et c'est c'est le pur
chasseurs si je puis dire deux jours
passés la station en premier est on est
on pourchasse un bon très bien j'en
profite également pour dire que vous
avez sans doute des questions j'en ai
beaucoup de questions mais je vais pas
toutes les poses équivoques qui
m'échappe charles pourra y répondre
allez sur nos plateformes et fait
acheminer comme ça vos questions et on
pourrait aller choisir au cours de
l'émission au cours de la prochaine
heure et demie changera probablement
être qu'on va prendre des questions et
auxquels il peut répondre on va faire
votre n'était pas génial astronautes à
l'acte est chargé pas on va aller jeter
un coup d'oeil aux prévisions du temps
justement à baïkonour au sujet oui oui
tout à fait on a vu un autre collègue
tamare altéré sco qui étaient là bas
juste ça semble être bien dégagé une
petite brise on le voyait dans les
cheveux et le port paume où j'ai observé
donc effectivement on a un ciel assez
bien dégagé de ce côté là aucun problème
on devrait avoir bon on a remarqué aussi
que tout le monde mais quand même vêtu
de ses shows demain on parle d'une
température actuellement à -2 degrés et
puis évidemment ça va descendre dans au
cours des prochaines heures mais pour le
dépassa devrait situer autour de ça avec
un vent sud-ouest avait 23 kilomètres à
l'heure où à peu près mais il devrait
pas avoir de changement de ce côté et
donc des conditions parfaites pour des
collèges mais je pense d'avoir entendu
qu ont décollé beau temps mauvais de
l'auteur mollet droit alors c'est ça on
a donc ce que je vous disais si elles
généralement dégagé avec un petit mot
sud-ouest à 23 km à la température
actuelle à -2 degrés donc des conditions
parfaites idéal finalement pas ma
musique ici chez nous merci au revoir
voici les images en direct du cosmodrome
baïkonour on voit les les
mes deux bras à l'état qui sont qui
descend tranquillement donc on est à
quelque chose comme à une trentaine de
minutes maintenant du lancement j'en
profite pour vous dire qu'on attend
aussi le point de presse de l' agence
spatiale canadienne puisqu'on est réuni
tout le monde est debout et tout le
monde et il a probablement ce matin pour
voir s'il y aura des représentants y
aura notamment une futur astronaute
canadienne qui prendra la parole à ce
moment là pour s'adresser à tout ce qui
suit ça de près ou de loin au collège de
maisonneuve également l'alma mater de
david singer qu'on est là je crois que
même au collège de montréal aussi on
suit tout ça tous ces préparatifs on a
vu revenir on a vu reculer
c'est étonnant et déjà posé la question
mais pourquoi ces deux programmes russes
et on décolle du kazakhstan mais c'était
à l'époque de la de la grande union de
la grande urss le kazakhstan est une des
républiques soviétiques socialiste
socialistes soviétiques de ligne éthique
et ils ont quand l'union soviétique a
implosé il irait on a eu donc la
fédération de russie qui a demeuré et
puis les anciennes républiques beaucoup
d'entre elles ont formé des états
indépendants dont le kazakhstan mais
sont entendus rapidement avec moscou
pour que moscou continue à utiliser
cette immense base spatiale qui est qui
et baïkonour c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment étonnant
et ce qui est ils ont ils ont pu
conserver donc ce qu'il faisait à
l'époque et quand on regarde ces
bases-là way est con con qu'on suit le
programme américain depuis des années on
sourit parce qu'on se rend compte à quel
point les russes ont fait des choses
différemment
d'abord la fusée soyouz n'arrive pas à
la verticale comme les anciens saturn ou
la navette spatiale sur le crip y croire
la verticale le sioux zarif coucher
serein sans être sur un wagon de train
aujourd'hui rails tout simplement
et puis quand on arrive au pas de tir
est bien allé tout simplement redresser
dans la position qui lui est nécessaire
pour le décollage que là on a vu les
braquer fait qu'ils étaient écartés
d'autres il a quatre qui vont tenir la
fusée jusqu'à jusqu'au décollage
oui parce que comme des commandes mais
parce que comme des dps la tiennent au
sol
oui on va tout et c'est ça exactement et
c'est par des contrepoids que tout cela
va s'ouvrir
les américains eux il avait au fond une
structure verticale à côté de la fusée
et quand la fusée décoller il fallait
déjà qu'elles commencent à s'écarter un
tout petit peu de la structure
métallique pour pas rentrer dedans mais
les russes ont fait quelque chose de
différent ils sont dit mais non ce qu'on
va faire c'est que les bras qui
retiennent la fusée coque avant juste au
moment où la fusée par mes bras ces
cartes comme une fleur comme des pétales
de fleurs et il a fusé s'élèvent ces
deux façons complètement différente de
concevoir le pâtir ça c'est vraiment
fascinant
vous avez bien raison parce que si on
recule au 11 octobre les re sont
rapidement analyser quel était le
problème
on l'a fixé c'est une tige de capteurs
qui a été percuté au montage à baïkonour
apparemment voulons c'est l'hypothèse
sur laquelle on travaille six avaient
été probablement la nasa on serait
encore en comité en comité sénatorial
denquin probablement pour comprendre ce
qui s'est passé il y aurait une enquête
beaucoup plus longue est tristement
il y aurait probablement eu mort d'homme
c'est ce qui est arrivé dans quatre
challenges le cas justement le
propulseurs d'appoint a percuté n'a pas
percuté mais à une flamme qui sortie du
du propulseurs d'appoint parce que les
joints d'étanchéité ne fonctionnait pas
bien quand il faisait très froid
le décollage a été fait dans des
températures trop froide pour le
caoutchouc de ce joint d'étanchéité qui
devenait friable la flamme est sorti à
l'aller chez le réservoir principal et
seul à exposer art là il ya eu un délai
de deux ans et demi et une enquête qui a
duré des mois et des mois dans ce cas ci
les russes était certain de ce qui
s'était passé
les américains ont dû sentir brassée par
la vitesse à laquelle ils ont 10 ans
recommence
oui mais ils ont confiance ils ont dit
oui
les canadiens aussi est ce qu'il faut
considérer ce qui a quand même eu quatre
lancements de fusées soyouz 2 puis 3 qui
était pas tout à fait le même modèle
pour transporter des satellites mais le
quatrième qui a été envoyée le 16
novembre si je me souviens bien c'était
la fusée identique à celle qui va
décoller aujourd'hui et ça s'est très
très bien passé c'était pour envoyer un
progress le progrès c'est une capsule
soyouz finalement qui contient du cargo
pour la station spatiale internationale
et qui s'amarrent automatiquement et
tout s'est très bien passé mais il ya
quand même eu cet incident de la le
soyouz qui avait un petit trou dans la
partie habitable le sioux ce qui est
actuellement ancré à la station spatiale
loin on sait pas toujours comment ça
c'est fait on pense que tu une foreuse
qui l'a fait probablement au sol quand
le tout a été soit construit ou
assemblée ça a été bloquée par de la
colle époxy suffisant ça c'est tout à
fait les russes dans des méthodes
d'essai américain où les américains
aussi parce que là haut ils ont des
méthodes sain pour ce genre de choses
parce que la partie habitable ne revient
pas dans l'atmosphère c'est à dire elle
revient elle est détruite
les astronautes sont pas à bord ils se
séparent de cette sphère la bon très
bien allons nous indique maintenant
qu'il ya de l'action à l'agent spécial
car
nous allons aller écouter d'ailleurs
c'est des gens qui prennent la parole de
vous accueillir en six grands noms et de
partager avec nous ce moment historique
dans le programme spatial canadien mais
sans plus tarder j'aimerais vraiment
vous présentez un invité spécial qui est
avec nous c'est un honneur et un
privilège pour nous de voir un honorable
de type d'art deep reçu d'avis practice
tête ce match le minime l'innovation des
sciences et du développement économique
mr freeze jane austen staged sera ce
film
thank you very much
[Applaudissements]
et narbonne mi journée une époque pour
moi les journées pour 2,8 à leur merci
merci pour cette présentation le petit
pour votre accueil chaleureux
en ce matin très tôt mais très
intéressant cette année unique de vivre
l'expérience en direct du lancement et
du départ d'un astronaute canadien dans
l'espace je me sens prêt viager d'être
ici aujourd'hui a dit qin six familles
vous pouvez voir dans la pièce ici le
canada a une longue histoire spatiale
beaucoup de canadiens sont fiers de
notre programme spatial et aujourd'hui
est un moment extraordinaire pour tous
les canadiens un moment que je vais
parler avec ma jeune fille qui n'a pas
pu me rejoindre parce qu'elle doit aller
à l'école mais nous allons reparler de
ce moment pour des années comment devait
se sentent ils alors pour un voyage de
toute une ville est ce parce que nous
inspirer lui magnette l'humanité aspirer
plus haut et ce défi
quel espace nous encourage à dépasser
les limites du possible
dans les premières minutes après le
décollage
le soyouz va déployer des millions de
chevaux vapeur il va atteindre une
vitesse orbitale de presque 92 mille
kilomètres harry l'équipe voyager d'une
distance d'ici à saint jean alors david
de ta vie de devenir le neuvième
canadien neuvième assaut nos canadiens
il passera six mois dans l'espace à bord
de laboratoire international et je sais
que bob bob a passé 187 jours il va
passer quelques jours de plus que vous
alors désolé
et durant cette période et le conduire à
2,9 expérience dans le domaine de la
santé et quelques expériences
internationales il testera de nouvelles
technologies et oui il le devra aussi le
bras spatial canadien
chacune des photos qu'ils nous renvoient
rats avec tous les contrats qui leur
avec nous il nous amènera sur 7 avec
cette avance dans cette aventure
extraordinaire dans deux semaines il y a
deux semaines nous avons célébré le 20e
anniversaire de la de bateaux spatiale
internationale ssi 20 ans de
collaboration presse ific
dans le projet d'ingénierie le plus
complexe ce probablement de l'histoire
humaine
cette station nous a permis de
comprendre comment travailler et vivre
ensemble dans l'espace g je vais suivre
la mission de la ville dans sa
manipulation des repos notre son test de
nouvelles technologies mais
particulièrement de voir le drapeau
canadien cousue sur son épaule qui va
encourager les jeunes canadiens à
l'hiver les étoiles nous décrire ce
qu'il ressent ce moment personne n'est
mieux placé qu'un astronaute qui est
déjà allé en mission est quelqu'un qui
suivra en jour ces traces saute à feu
doux et maps ou alors c'est mon honneur
absolue de bienvenue à bord le premier
astronaute canadien à nous asseoir et
notre nouvel astronaute ceux qui veulent
une nouvelle recrue alors je les invite
à monter sur scène ici et de partager
avec nous les quelques minutes qui s'en
vient
[Applaudissements]
bonjour tout le monde je suis jeune et
sa rigueur benz je suis très content
d'être ici pour partager ce moment avec
vous sur la tête j'ai été choisi dans la
dernière campagne de recrutement
d'astronautes canadiens en juillet 2018
et depuis je m'entraîne au texas je suis
là la dernière fois que j'étais ici
c'était la dernière fois que nationaux
canadiens lancée dans l'espace c'était
pour mon copain aujourd'hui c'est une
aventure tout particulier parce qu'un
autre sono canadien qui s'en va pour
l'espace
je pense qu'on a besoin d'avoir plus
d'astronautes canadiens pour qu'ils
puissent venir ici plus souvent alors
après une décennie de préparation rides
entraîne david saint-jacques est prêt à
faire le voyage spatial et ça prend
beaucoup de travail de six que pour lui
ça a été un rêve de toute une vie
alors regardons d'un peu plus près le
genre d'entraînement nécessaire
le 3 décembre 2018
david saint-jacques astronaute de
l'agencé spatiale canadienne s'envolera
vers la station spatiale internationale
après une dizaine d'années de
préparation dont des milliers d'heures
de formation et l'entraînement je suis
sur le point de réaliser
c'est en 2008 de laventure de david
saint jacques pour devenir un jour
astronomes
d
après un long processus de sélection de
plus de 20 ans au mois de mai d'une
union d'un médecin jacques est recruté
par l'agencé spatiale canadienne
il devient officiellement astronautes
canadiens quand j'ai appris que j'avais
des sélectionnés j'ai réalisé à quel
point j'étais privilégiées peu de gens
ont cette chance
il débute alors une longue formation y
suit diverses d'entraînement pour
enquiller toutes les connaissances
nécessaires à sa nouvelle vocation la
formation l'entraînement ont été
exigeants complexes qu'elles aboutissent
2016 qu'on annonce que david
saint-jacques est affecté à une mission
c'est officiel
il partira dans l'espace
je suis honorée de représenter les
canadiens dans cette mission vous m'avez
choisie vous m'avez forme et oum
accorder votre confiance je promets de
faire de mon mieux pour être à la
hauteur de vos autres david est
maintenant affectés à sa première
mission il doit suivre un programme de
formation sur mesure de parer son séjour
dans l'espace
c'est une mission de six mois à bord de
la station spatiale internationale qui
maintenant
depuis des mois je partage mon temps le
canada
les raf
[Musique]
le japon
ici
et les états unis me préparais missions
spatiales
l'entraînement et la formation de david
sont officiellement terminées maintenant
avoir la chance de mettre en application
toutes les connaissances et les
compétences que j'ai hâte
[Musique]
3 décembre 2018 c'est le jour j tu avais
de saint jacques vincent relais de
baïkonour au kazakhstan pour rejoindre
la station spatiale internationale
enfin prêt à me rapprocher des étoiles
on se revoit dans l'espace
[Musique]
frans
[Rires]
alors c'est la présentation en direct de
l'agent spatiale canadienne diane ladd
dans un châle madame sa dégaine ce qui
se dit à l'écouté je vois ce que ce que
ça peut dire ce que ça peut représenter
9 ans de travail mais on entend
également le ministre quand il dit ça
prend plus de canadiens ou à monsieur
torchis également le 10 mai tout est une
fonction du fait que ce sont les russes
qui lance maintenant les astronautes et
les cosmonautes ans il ya moins de place
il n'y a pas de programme américain dans
le moment là on ne pense pas c'est à
dire que si le canada pouvait contribuer
plus est la station spatiale
internationale
on aurait plus d'astronautes plus
rapidement dans l'espace c'est vrai
qu'en ce moment c'est les russes qui
sont les seuls à pouvoir lancer des amis
en orbite mais il ya quand même d'autres
solutions qui sont en préparation il ya
spacek ce actuellement avec la capsule
dragon qui en principe sera sera testé
en janvier si tout va bien non pas avec
des usa à bord mais sans humain et c'est
une capsule qui devrait pouvoir si tout
va bien d'ici environ un an peut-être
moins commencé à transporter des
astronautes américains boeing aussi à sa
capsule sur le travail qui est un petit
peu moins avancé que le dragon de spacex
l'image que vous voyez là et en direct
c'est du pas de tir de baïkonour ben
david saint jacques se trouve justement
dans la capsule
tout en hausse de 7 de cette fusée vous
excuser et on vous donnera l'occasion de
revenir là dessus bien sûr au cours des
prochaines minutes le départ le
lancement c'est dans moins de quinze
minutes maintenant
prévoyant des contents on a reçu des
questions et y adhérer gilbert qui
viennent nous écrit charles qui vous
pose la question quelle est la forge et
que les astronautes doivent subir au
décollage alors savary des 40 secondes
après le décollage on est déjà rendu à
1,5 g c'est à dire 1,5 fois la gravité
terrestre quand on est sur terre sont
voilà le point été augmentées de 1,5
et puis déjà à 2 minutes 20 secondes
les forces g monte à 3,5 g et ça c'est
le moment le plus intense pour les peaux
pour les astronautes durant la première
phase de l'ascension c'est la période où
vraiment là tout le vaisseau et la fusée
vous rencontrer des résistances
atmosphériques très fort en accélérant
quant à cette hauteur à cette vitesse là
oui oui un deux minutes deux minutes
devinrent on continue à accélérer et en
fait vous avez totalement raison c'est
l'accès des ratios qui causent des
forges et on peut être à 25 mille
kilomètres à l'heure et boire un verre
d'eau tranquillement c'est vrai boire un
verre d'eau tranquillement non parce
qu'on est dans l'espace la bulle ne
s'écrase pas contre le mur personne
accélère pas ces cantons accélérations
mais dans sa voiture et puis qu'on donne
un bon coup d'accélérateur là on sent la
pression sur le dos c'est ce qu'on
appelle la force g qui s'applique
ghislain boutin une autre question pour
vous sharks elle est la vitesse au
décollage la vitesse au décollage
varient évidemment à 0,00 sais rien mais
déjà à quelques secondes de
depuis le décollage on atteint des
vitesses progressivement de plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres
neuf mille dix mille 13000 jusqu'à 27
milles à peu près 700 kilomètres à
l'heure quand on se satellise et tout ça
se fait en neuf minutes en gsm et c'est
fantastique
vous savez quand on parle de la vitesse
0 0 à 100 km à l'heure en voiture on
dire ça prend 5,6 secondes dans un
bolide
oui là on va 25 25 mille kilomètres à
l'heure neuf minutes mais ça fait rêver
bon merci pour les questions continuer à
nous faire parvenir vos questions comme
ça ça va animer notre discussion et
probablement les propos parce qu'on va
retrouver qui me permette qui se trouve
au collège de maisonneuve là où a étudié
d'ailleurs d'investir encore là aussi on
va suivre l'événement de près ouais
évidemment marc andré ya beaucoup de
fébrilité dans l'air parce qu'ici on a
très hâte d'assister à ce lancement
environ une centaine de personnes qui
sont attendues citant des étudiants que
des employés du collège que des parents
il ya même des élèves qui ont dormi ici
cette nuit pour être certain de ne rien
manquer de ce grand lancement parce que
vous l'avez dit david saint-jacques à
étudier ici en sciences de la nature il
a obtenu son diplôme en 1989
est ce que je vous dis je vous dis on va
peut-être vous surprendre c'est le
premier diplômé du collège de
maisonneuve à s'envoler dans le sport
l'art évidemment qu'ici c'est une source
de fierté j'ai parlé à quelques
étudiants qui voulaient venir assister
au lancement on peut les écouter mais
moi je sais pas si l'espace et c'est la
première fois que j'assiste à un
événement aussi grand soit ça que je
suis ici ce matin
ah ben moi j'aime pas c'est nous qui est
de la stratégie je trouve david saint
jacques c'est une personne toutes
simples pillés
j'ai vu plusieurs fois dans mon lit dans
ma vie est venue d'un des conférences à
mon école primaire pays venant cette
écologie fakih est quand même j'ai quand
même je trouve un lien avec lui puis on
se laisse des regrets quand il s'en veut
dans sa mission spatiale
c'est une personne qui quand même
accessible c'est aussi quelque chose
d'exceptionnel à ceci le tout le triage
qui on pourrait rire s
cette position-là de dettes la personne
qui décolle c'est exceptionnel
et il ya également sur place deux
professeurs qui ont brièvement enseigné
à david singer évidemment sont très
excités ce matin de se trouver sur place
et d'assister à ce grand lancement on
aura d'ailleurs l'occasion de leur
parler un petit peu plus tard et
d'ailleurs autre raison pour le collège
de maisonneuve d'être très fier ce matin
c'est que ce petit drapeau du collège de
maisonneuve que vous voyez aura lui
aussi sa place dans l'espace puisque
david saint-jacques là à bord de ses
valises nous dit on alors voilà comme je
disais une centaine de personnes qui
sont attendues si ce matin on leur a
même offert le déjeuner pour l'occasion
et la belle se diriger tranquillement
dans la salle est évidemment qu'on aura
l'occasion de vous revenir avec toutes
les réactions de faux que ce lancement
ce sera finalement déroulé bombay le
régistraire est mieux d'être prêt là au
collège de maisonneuve parce que le
programme sciences de la nature va
peut-être avoir attiré un petit boost un
peu comme les lanceurs soyouz merci
beaucoup qui est mon héros vous
retrouver on a hâte d'entendre les profs
de ce 9e astronautes canadiens justement
alors nous sommes plus ou moins six
minutes là maintenant du décollage et
comme nous vous le disions chant n'est
ce pas on les voit les trois astronautes
vous allez nous les situer probablement
là je crois bien que ils sont ils sont
bien en place fait prêt à partir donc
dans quelques minutes maintenant
oui alors celui qui est au centre c'est
au legs c'est le commandant de bord et
le pilote à sa gauche c'est david
saint-jacques et puis et puis
anne madeleine et de l'autre côté donc à
droite du commandant qui est intéressant
c'est que le commandant lui doit appuyer
sur les boutons là on voit pas des
cerveaux maintenant mais là une tige et
une baguette c'est ce que j'allais vous
demandez pas ce qu'il est un pur un
petit peu trop loin
alors il a très entraînés bien sûr il
appuie sur les boutons avec sa tige
les autres peuvent le faire manuellement
directement avec avec leurs doigts
alors là on voit la fusée c'est
impressionnant parce que vous savez une
fusi est à 90% du carburant jouer ici à
310 tonnes de carburant sous les
astronautes c'est une configuration la
plus sécuritaire possible quand la
capsule est au dessus des réservoirs
elle les astronautes eurent beaucoup
plus protégé que par exemple dans le cas
de la navette où les astronautes étant
dans la navette qui était elle même
collé sur le réservoir principal on
pouvait dire les astronautes étaient
collés sur le réservoir à l'oeil vous
pouvez dire que les dans les navettes
américaines l'équipage était à peu près
coiro au thiem puisqu'elle admet même
facilement au-dessus de la demie parce
que il était dans la cabine de pilotage
qui elle même était au sommet de la
navette
dans ce cas ci c'est une configuration
plus classique est beaucoup plus
sécuritaires américains d'ailleurs sont
revenus à cette configuration là et il
faut savoir que là encore la proche des
russes est différente
cette fusée à une grappe de propulseurs
quatre propulseurs d'appoint qui ce qui
entoure la fusée à sa base
ici on voit toujours les astronautes et
le cosmonaute russe qui sont très calmes
très très serein face à ceux à ce
décollage c'est vraiment impressionnant
de voir cela et au tout début les
moteurs à la base même du camp principal
de la fusée s'allument les chiffres des
quatre propulseurs d'appoint qui sont en
grave tout autour s'allume également et
puis la cuisine ne lève pas tout de
suite ça prend une dizaine de secondes
peut-être même un peu plus pour que la
puissance arrive à son maximum on
chauffe les matins on chauffe les
moteurs on s'assure que toutes les
pressions sont bonnes que les pompes qui
vont chercher le kérosène
parce que c'est un véhicule qui est
animé par de l'oxygène liquide et du
kérosène que le kérosène et l'oxygène
liquide arrivent ensemble à la bonne
pression pour que justement l'étincelle
qui se fait à la base allume le tout est
que la pression de cette explosion
contrôlée soit parfaite
à ce moment-là à 00 00 on va voir le
soleil s'est levé dans ciel là il va
aller de plus en plus vite et on va voir
les bras mécanique s'écarter il le faut
par gravité encore une solution simple
par des contrepoids tout simplement en
amateur on risque pas une défaillance de
moteurs puisque ça se fait par la bonne
vieille gravité terrestre et toute cette
mission là c'était c'est un ballet entre
les machines les humains et la gravité
terrestre et ça sera en plusieurs étapes
aussi j'en profite peut-être que vous
pourrez donner des détails champ mais
d'abord ce que l'on verra tombé à peu
près vous avez mentionné 2020 tout à
l'heure en fait c'est à 7 environ à 2
minutes qu'on va voir les propulseurs
d'appoint se détacher du corps principal
de la fusion quoi il tombera en croit
dans cette extraordinaire croire et on
devrait les voir pas je pense qu'on les
a vues sur un autre des caladons il ya
une caméra d'installer le dessus exact
c'est très possible qu'on puisse le voir
et ça c'est un moment critique parce que
il faut que la libération se fasse bien
et que la fusée puisse donc continuer
sur l'ascension sans les propulseurs
d'appoint
c'est ensuite il ya d'autres étapes
d'autres étages l'acquis qui sont
largués progressivement aussi quoi à peu
près à 4 minutes 48 c'est et plus tard
vers quoi quatre minutes plus tard je
pense qu'à six nuls plus tard
effectivement le troisième étage va
pouvoir s'étendre et se séparer du
soyouz se propre mort a dit qui comprend
trois unités trois éléments comme on
sait
la partie habitable la partie piloter et
la partie technique également et donc ça
c'est le vaisseau soyouz qui va être
séparé de du troisième étage lorsqu'on
arrivera
près de neuf minutes de vol - l'état
malgré ce qu'on nous disait tout à
l'heure précisément à 6h31 et 58 je les
prend en note
ce sera le décollage donc ce sera
effectivement à partir de maintenant
c'est top
deux minutes avant le décollage à ce
moment là les ordinateurs les
séquenceurs sont prêts est-ce que tout à
coup l'on va donner le signal et
l'ordinateur prendra le contrôle de ce
lancement c'est toujours des moments
excitants est-ce que je suis passionné
je sais pas si ce sera seulement camp
russe on le verra bien mais on va les
écouter les communications les toutes
dernières communications avant le départ
de saint jacques pour les étoiles
c'est très serein en ce moment il ya
même pas de communication entre la
capsule et le centre de contrôle ce qui
est assez remarquable
enfin un autre de notre point de vue à
nour l'entendent pas et on peut présumer
que c'est la situation on a fait ce
qu'on a fait toutes les vérifications
avant lé directeur de vol lé directeur
c'est extrêmement voilà on va retirer
les les bras et tout moment sur leur
propre pouvoir maintenant leur propre
énergie sont séparés le ced du pâtir le
véhicule est autonome
[Musique]
avec
tous les paramètres sont bons c'est ce
qu'on nous indique que ça tout à fait
normal dans prochaine étape c'est bien
et bien maintenant dans quelques
secondes dizaine de secondes vous allez
voir les quatre propulseurs d'appoint
être largué la capsule et la coiffe du
soyouz qu'il protège de l'espace a
maintenant été largués également au
sommet de la fusée russe soyouz ici sur
l'animation
parce que sa coiffe son compartiment
protecteur
là on est dans la partie de résistance
importante pour les instruments qui sont
en juillet j'ai important ici au delà de
trois filles
[Musique]
tout se passe très bien chaque fois vous
entendez le mot dans une minute il y
aura donc une autre qui sera largué
on approche du moment où le second et le
troisième étage va se déclencher deux
secondes avant que le deuxième étage
n'hésitez pas c'est assez remarquable
[Musique]
subissant des jets considérable
également mais ça c'est une étape
critique qui vient d'être franchi je
rappelle qu'ils sont dans cette phase
d'ascension là avant d'arriver alors
bits c'est dur quelque chose comme neuf
minutes donc en décollant à peu près
trente deux 32 qu'elle nous arrive à 41
donc encore trois minutes et demie avant
d'attaquer
quoi qu on écoute attentivement la
spéciale si il ya bien des gens qui font
des quelques les qui observe et qui
regarde un bien de certainement leur
expertise et leur permettre de voir des
choses différemment ou d'entendre
peut-être des choses et à plus de 13 14
min kilomètres à l'heure la plus de 170
km d'altitude
tout va bien à bord ils sont très bien
ont déjà communiqué il y avait aucun
problème de leur côté
s'étonnant de voir jusqu'à quel point ce
voyage là est calme pour les astronautes
qui est pas le cas de certains autres
fusées elle est très très stable et peu
de vibrations c'est assez rare car je
vous disais tout à l'heure d'observer le
toutou parce que j'avais vu sur d'autres
et qui bougeait était il faisait des
cercles et là maintenant voix j'ai vu
les plus chaudes sud avait tiré de ne
pas bouger du tout il y en a qui nous
envoie comme question seulement est ce
que pour combattre cette recette gravité
les astronautes et cosmonautes sont
soumis à un régime spécial avant de
partir non mais évidemment ils doivent
être en excellente forme physique parce
que le corps subit des pressions
auxquelles on n'est pas habitué sur
terre mais c'est surtout leur
entraînement et leur condition physique
qui leur permettent de résister à ce
genre de choses et puis bien sûr sur
terre ils ont été notés beaucoup de
tests et leur permet de s'habituer quand
ils arriveront à l'aluminé 4,5 seulement
au niveau pour six étages d'une
facilitation
[Musique]
station spatiale on a la capsule est
l'espèce de compartiments l'arrière on
est en orbite
là les approches du moment où ils sont
synthétisés sinon il faut déjà cette
église et voilà ils sont ils ont atteint
l'orbité et parler des petits petits
nounours la dent live ils vont flotter
maintenant c'est pour ça qu'ils émettent
la de kiel et moi flotter savent qu'ils
sont en apesanteur les choses les plus
simples
pourquoi avoir alors là ils ont atteint
leurs beats qui va falloir déterminer
maintenant s'ils ont atteint la norme il
visé parce qu'encore une fois ci
atteigne l'orbité visée ils peuvent
rejoindre la station spatiale
internationale en syrie
le principe les antennes et les panneaux
solaires vont se déployer panneaux
solaires évidemment importer de
l'électricité de l'énergie pour sauver
sa peau en carafe
enfin tout indique iso appelant lieu de
vous parce que si le commandant a pu
voir 10 de l'espace le décalage est ce à
dire qu'il était parfaitement impuni
très suffisamment près les collages ses
fesses parfaites l'aube au bon moment ça
on le savait mais ce qu'il fallait être
ce dont il fallait être certain c'est
que les mateurs a bien fonctionné à la
puissance vous luttez pour la durée
voulu la durée voulu on est on est on
était sur la puissance d'alain honda on
a eu un début de confirmation par et le
comique acteur ici de la nasa qui nous
indique ainsi six heures pour atteindre
la station spatiale internationale à
partir de maintenant
donc ça c'est très très très rassurant
ça ça indique qu'ils ont atteint leur
vie de voulu et maintenant les
astronautes ont un orbite complet 90
minutes pour s'assurer que tous les
systèmes fonctionnent bien et qu'ils
vont pouvoir effectuer ce rendez vous
avec la station spatiale internationale
c'est très important il faut s'assurer
que que que tout et nominales comme on
dit
parce que encore une fois ci un problème
bien ils ont plein de solutions
possibles et pour l'instant tout indique
que ça va très bien je vous renvoie vous
avez dit qu'on a une rotation donc 90
minutes donc à ce stade là si dans 80
minutes ont trouvé quelque chose on
pourra en tant que mécanisme pour
revenir surtout il ya toujours la
possibilité de séparer au fond la
capsule qu'ils habitent actuellement qui
est pilotable qui pilotait et qui a le
bouclier thermique qui est extrêmement
solide même très épais et qui leur
permettrait de revenir dans la danse
dans l'atmosphère et de se poser de se
poser sur terre donc je pense que
l'allemagne maintenant ils sont dans une
situation qui est qui est vraiment
sécuritaire et tout indique la mission
se déroule tel que prévu il n'y a pas
lieu de penser qu' ils ne vont pas
pouvoir entamer le rendez vous tels que
prévu ce sont des vérifications qui sont
tout à fait normales régulière et qui
font partie de leur travail habituel
pour s'assurer que ils peuvent ensuite
entamer l'étape suivante tout se fait
par étapes évidemment
on attend d'ailleurs d'une minute à
l'autre le point de presse de l'agencé
spatiale canadienne qui suit tout ça
qu'il ya des gens ou commander à
l'écouté qui est déjà là bas également à
baïkonour qui suit l'évolution de ce
dossier là donc dès que dès qu'ils
seront en mesure de nous en dire
davantage on pourrait le faire
charles je reviens encore une fois quand
on pense à toutes ces tous ces
préparatifs
on sait qu'il y six allemands ils
devaient décoller le 20 décembre et là
maintenant on dit ben bella oui comme on
a eu un pépin on va devancer les choses
vous décollez le 3 si vous dire à quel
point on s'entraîne et on s'en fait
déplacer un vol commercial le devancer
dix jours ce serait déjà 10 et ce
quelque chose
mais jean yves on va dans l'espace on
devance de dix jours et ça se fait
facilement très surprenant pour les
américains des canadiens
d'habitude les choses se font de façon
beaucoup plus sa propre état mais il
faut dire que les russes ont tellement
l'habitude de ce système là de ce
vaisseau là qu'il coûtait exploite le
soyouz depuis des années 60
c'est toujours la même fusée qui a été
améliorée qui a été modifiée mais c'est
toujours la même fusée
c'est toujours le même concept et donc
ils ont pu cibler le problème qu'ils ont
tués au mois d'octobre rapidement et ils
sont certains que il a été corrigé parce
qu'il fallait se poser trois questions
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi ça
s'est passé
et peut-on le peut-on prévenir que ce
peut-on s'assurer que ça ne se
reproduira pas alors quand ils ont eut
répondu à ces titres en question là bas
ils ont dit on y va
les américains ont dit mon bain très
bien on vous suit et puis regardez on
voit que jusqu'à maintenant les choses
se sont se sont très bien déroulées oui
c'est naturellement un moment de
réjouissance pour tous ces gens-là de
l'agent ce que l'on voit ici lors qu'il
faut qu'ils sont photographiés à côté
ben justement en deux sets de cette
image de david scène puisqu'il faut dire
c'est que suite à ce que vous venez de
mentionner le fait que la que les dates
étaient échangés ça veut dire aussi
qu'il ya deux astronautes de - la roue
les deux astronautes qui n'ont pas pu se
rendre à cause de l'incident dioses du
11 octobre
s'il avait pu s'y rendre et 5
astronautes à bord en ce moment et les
équipages actuels en arrivant à la
station
il aurait été remplacé il aurait
remplacé l'équipage de trois astronautes
qui seraient revenus sur terre donc les
deux qui auraient dû y aller aurait été
la plus les 3 qui arrive maintenant ça
fait 5
oui et ça prend au moins cinq
astronautes pour pouvoir au fond faire
tout l'entretien ni vaisseau spatial et
les tests scientifiques aussi point ça
prend au moins trois astronautes sur une
base régulière pour entretenir les
systèmes pour s'assurer que tout est
sécuritaire vous et que tout fonctionne
bien
là ils ne sont plus que 3 voici celui
voir que lille en manque redevenir
manquera deux donc vont-ils pouvoir
faire toutes les expériences
scientifiques qu'il voulait faire il ya
un point d'interrogation à ce niveau là
et ça c'est le côté qui est un petit peu
décevant dans ce qui s'est passé en
octobre il va manquer 2 2 deux
coéquipiers à partir de maintenant
à partir du 20 décembre parce que les
autres vont revenir le 20 décembre
les trois qui sont qui sont en surplus
vont revenir de 3 décembre
et puis on pense que dans trois mois
environ il ya un nouvel équipage qui va
se rendre alors pour au moins trois mois
là ils vont seulement et 3 et ses ordres
de deux vaisseaux qui font entretenir
continuellement
bon on va tout de suite se rendre en
agence spatiale canadienne où on a on
est sur le point de nous livrer les
premières impressions de ce lancement
ce 9e canadien ce neuvième assaut
d'autres qui se trouvent dans l'espace
alors notre gouvernement soutient le
programme spatial c'est un point de
fierté pour beaucoup de canadiens de
l'état jacques été une inspiration pour
beaucoup de jeunes et c'est pour ça que
le gouvernement canadien va dépenser un
demi milliard de dollars dans le
programme spatial depuis 2015 alors d'un
point de vue aujourd'hui est un exemple
de l'importance de ce programme pour
inspirer les jeunes canadiens et
canadiennes nous avons plusieurs
astronautes de premier plan ils veulent
parler du programme spatial nous
travaillons sur une stratégie spatiale
sur un programme spatial et nous avons
eu une rencontre positive très
productive avec les administrateurs de
la nasa lors on se voit et impliqué dans
l'aventuré spatiale pour bien des années
encore nous allons continuer de soutenir
ce programme beaucoup d'opportunités
pour tous les canadiens particulièrement
pour nos enfants
aujourd'hui david saint jacques il
il est il il était incroyable expérience
pour moi et je suis prêt
un confident nous allons continuer à
aider et continuer à aider les
programmes pour l'espace et familiale
accède à ford et comme j'étais en tant
que parent de deux jeunes filles
c'est ce programme est une source
d'inspiration et je crois que jenny et
bob peuvent en parler pour parler de la
pointue en tant qu astronomes je pense
encore une fois c'est une source de
fierté pour tous les canadiens
canadiennes nous avons une histoire
spatiale c'est un moment de célébrer
cette histoire nous savons nous
célébrons le 20e anniversaire de la
station spatiale internationale encore
city importance est capitale pour nos
enfants nous si les élit les bénéfices
qui découlent de ces de ce programme
beaucoup de recherches rendent maîtres
de la santé comme jenny a mentionné
d'être sur le coeur l'uso le système
circulatoire aussi la technologie comme
le bras canadien envoie des impacts
possibles direct comment les recherches
sur un banc canadien améliorer
l'industrie
alors on a des applications réelles en
devises impact réel sur la vie de tous
les gens et programme spatial est
d'améliorer la vie de tous une lèvre et
aujourd'hui maintenant c'est vrai avec
commencer maintenant
david dans l'espace il commence cette ce
travail pour le reste du canada
il inspire les jeunes canadiens de
suivre une formation dans les sciences
et aussi de inspiré la société canadien
de produits blé les choses difficiles
je veux moi souligné l'importance
d'avoir ces modèles ce modèle qui
réalisent leur rêve comme début de la
queue aujourd'hui c'est important pour
moi une chose frappe au dessus
aujourd'hui si ce n'était si l'un d'eux
programme spatial canadien n'avait pas
existé
alors ce voyage vous
nous apporter beaucoup de nouvelles
connaissances mais simplement le ce
qu'on a vu ce matin ce décollage déjà
des effets pouces l'horaire est très
occupé à bord d'un vaisseau spatial
chaque seconde est prévue planifié fait
partie d'un horaire et david va devoir
accomplir le travail faire attention au
rythme où il accomplit les choses mais
il doit aussi conservé un peu ces
énergies physiques et psychologiques
pour accompli toutes ces tâches
quand moi j'ai été dans l'espace la
chose qui était plus difficile c'est
d'être éloigné de ma famille des lois
est éloigné de ma planète mais sans
travail vole la technologie à bord de la
station spatiale va lui permettre
d'avoir des contacts avec sa famille
comme si elle va pouvoir se concentrer
sur le travail à faire j'ai manqué ma
famille c'était difficile de voler dans
l'espace de faire les choses
professionnels pour le programme
international de la station spatiale et
aussi de fond que je continuais à
fonctionner comme un père comme épouse
alors voilà un bon point de presse les
gens qui se sent très très inspiré
notamment
sa rigueur bonne spécialiste de
combustion des carburants
charles rapidement maintenant les gens
vont peut-être quitter vont revenir
suivre l'actualité spatiale ce lancement
quelle est la prochaine étape le conte
doit qu'on doit regarder qu'on doit voir
le crucial bien ça va être ça va être
bien sûr le rendez-vous s'assurer que le
soyouz pour rejoindre la station
spatiale internationale et qui va
pouvoir s'amarrer la procédure
d'amarrage et est extrêmement délicate
difficile à réaliser mais ça va se faire
automatiquement quand ça se fait
automatiquement puis cas pas de problème
d'ordinateur tout va très bien
l'étape suivante ça va être une
ouverture des écoutilles pour aller
visiter leur nouvelle maison qui
concerne encore la tâche aux frappes sur
la enfin on frappe sur les coups de cink
est d'accord avant de voir pressurer
s'assurer que tout est bien pressurisée
qui a pas de fuite qui a pas de petits
détritus dans les sauts d'étanchéité qui
pourrait créer une différence de
pression entre le sou news et la station
ça prend une heure ou deux une heure à
deux pour faire ça et quand ça sera fait
ce segment table sur la porte
les autres vont répondre les écoutilles
on s'ouvre et puis vont s'embrasser bon
tout le monde sera content mais très
bien mais c'est ce qu'on fera donc à
midi quoi 12h31 on a dit
ou à peu près cet arrimage donc ce sera
à suivre à chalon vous laisse aller
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin on va vous retrouver sur un peu
plus tôt ce matin pour résumer tout ça
pour voir où nous en serons un petit peu
plus tard ce matin on parlera également
à tabarre intéresse qu qui se trouvaient
à un kilomètre du lancement de soyouz ce
matin clic
[Musique]
un décollage réussi pour david saint
jacques et ses coéquipiers les trois
astronautes sont en route vers la
station spatiale internationale
je trouve un lien avec lui je vous
semences de revoir et 5 sans vie dans sa
mission spatiale dette la personne qui
décolle c'est exceptionnel étudiants
amis collègues ont suivi le décollage en
direct c'est un rêve qui devient réalité
pour l'astronaute canadien
le gouvernement de la cab dépose sa
première mise à jour économique y
aura-t-il des baisses d'impôts pour les
québécois encore quelques précipitations
verglaçantes forme de bruyne pour le
nord-est de l'ontario pluies
verglaçantes possible surtout ce matin
du côté de la grande région de québec
et si on se déplace un petit peu plus à
l'est le vent va se lever pour
terre-neuve une partie de la nouvelle
écosse donc ce sera avant tout de ce
côté là et on aura des températures qui
seront à la baisse à bien des endroits
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
c'est ce que disent les gens des
communications sur ces images que nous
voyons de la fusée soyouz qui
transportent l'astronaute canadien david
saint jacques il est maintenant en route
vers la station spatiale internationale
la fusée a décollé il y a trente minutes
du cosmodrome de baïkonour au kazakhstan
à ses côtés dans ce vaisseau se trouvent
le commandant russe oleg coloniale qu et
puis l'assaut note américaine un soyouz
doit s'arrimer avec la station spatiale
internationale plus tard cet après-midi
en fait un circuit ça dans votre agenda
à peu près aux environs de 12h30
david saint-jacques devient le premier
canadien à orbite et la terre depuis
chris hadfield il y a 6 ans nous allons
retrouver notre correspondante à baralle
des risques au qui est au cosmodrome
justement d'où elle assister à ce
lancement de la fusée soyouz ça devait
être un moment de grande émotion pour
les gens qui étaient présents dans
l'entourage de saint jacques
oui oui in motion et silence radio
il pas seulement pendant le décollage en
foire et jusqu'au 9 vidéo que la fusée a
besoin en vitesse pour te rendre d'orbey
et je voudrais tellement quand on a
abordé ici au micro pas que la fusée
était en orbite exactement l'idée
d'après son école a éclaté de joie les
applaudissements l'italie en larmes
parce que j'aime le dire que les
astronautes étaient hors de danger
ils sont en train de faire le tour de la
terre dans son 4 avant de s'amarrer à la
station spatiale internationale ion
depuis parlé pour la première fois
depuis trois jours on la voit cette
sphère éradique la phase de cézac avec
ses trois enfants
circuler dans paris que nous parler à
son avis à travers une vitre du moment
extrêmement émouvant et juste il
pourrait les ont finalement vaincu tu
parlais tout à l'heure elle était de
julie payette qui est grande à 19 habits
qu'on nous dise à quel point elle est
contente de savoir que tu avais singer
jeu l'asse est là où il voulait être
pour voir où on se parle on en laisse
passer du convoi exceptionnel privilège
de pouvoir y assister il le travail
commence
de ses moyens la plus longue pour un
canadien à bord de la station
on aura l'occasion dû parler dès ce soir
parce qu'il a produit une fois entré en
communication avec la terre pour une
conversation avec une première à paris
parce qu'on va d'évitement là mais les
cosmonautes et les astronautes ont des
accès privilégiés à l'internet et aux
communications à certaines périodes de
la journée donc on est relativement
contact mais dites moi c'est bien quel
point ça crée un engouement en floride
quand une une fusée ou une navette était
lancée est ce qu'on voit là qu'on voit
la même chose dans la population autour
de baïkonour
mais bike énorme et cliff que pour cela
donc les gens qui ont pu fiston habitués
de la paix autour du laboratoire de
l'agencé
donc c'est difficile et on peut pas
essayer de livres pour la première fois
on ne peut pas être insensible à voir
des humains décoller dans un tube de
métal tout petit lot par seulement de
méthane s'est il s'est quand même dit
celle-là fioul a rien à voir avec la
tablette face à des américains donc
devoir c'est de vos propres yeux les
couleurs différentes en personne les
voix sont pas le bruit est intense sinon
dieu et c'est absolument exceptionnel à
voir de près pour les gens qui ont
l'habitude de le voir c'était comme je
vous ai le silence radio tout le monde
après son succès des grands moments et
pour le canada qui envoie tout le moins
un chrono identique un important tout à
fait vous avez bien raison on continue à
vous à vous suivre je sais que vous
allez continuer à faire de la cueillette
il nous faire parvenir d'autres
témoignages alors on attend vos
nouvelles merci beaucoup
tamara plus tard même peuple et vais
revoir et bien sûr que ce décollage
était fébrilement suivi ce matin l'
agence spatiale canadienne
parce que mine à tous sont très très
fier d'avoir pu assister à ce grand
moment là il fallait entendre les
applaudissements nourris si dans la
salle de conférence de l'agencé spatiale
canadienne
quand l'ancien astronaute bob peeters
qui a officiellement annoncé que david
singer qui était un astronaute alors que
la capsule soyouz est officiellement
entré en orbite autour de la terre des
gens extrêmement fier tous les employés
de l'agent spécial ont insisté à ce
décollage par un 6h30 et une heure de
l'est alors un décollage sans faute qui
s'est très bien passé contrairement à
celui du 11 octobre dernier où on avait
dû carrément annulé le vol en ramenant
les astros d'autre part parachutage
alors david saint-jacques est
officiellement autour de la terre il va
effectuer quatre tours complets quatre
tours de 90 minutes avant de se mettre
en orbite est dans la même position
la même trajectoire que la station
spatiale internationale dont pendant six
heures il devrait être en mesure de
procéder à l'opération d'arrimage il est
le co pilote dans cette émission
david saint jacques fait également la
fierté ici l agence spatiale canadienne
parce que oui comme tamara le dit il
s'agit d'un astronaute 1 o5 environ qui
s'envole vers l'espace et c'est un homme
qui a grandi à saint lambert natif de
québec 48 ans est évidemment une feuille
de route très impressionnante
astrophysiciens et physiciens médecin de
famille donc il s'est entraîné durant
presque dix ans pour pouvoir s'envoler
vers ce voyage de six mois et demi on
vous a préparé les réactions du ministre
responsable de l'agencé spatiale
canadienne
l'afdi 'pays' on peut l'écouter
représente beaucoup d'opportunités pour
tous les canadiens particulièrement pour
nos enfants
aujourd'hui david saint jacques il
il est il il était incroyable expérience
pour moi et je suis prêt
confidents nous allons continuer à aider
et continuer à aider le programme pour
l'espace
alors david singer que concentrera ses
efforts par des expériences en
laboratoire la station spatiale
internationale est un immense
laboratoire qui se déplace à 28 milles
kilomètres heure environ autour de la
terre il sera principalement l'objet de
ses propres recherches parce que le
programme spatial canadien est
concentrée présentement sur les effets
de l'apesanteur sur le corps humain
on va utiliser entre autres le
vieillissement du corps humain on sait
que six mois dans l'espace a et qui voit
dix ans de vie humaine sur terre
comment le corps réagit les eaux alors
ce sont des expériences qui vont avoir à
l'époque ici sur terre dans la recherche
médicale peut conduire à des chasseurs
des médicaments des traitements
ultérieurement dans un avenir plus ou
moins rapproché merci beaucoup pascal
envers tout va sans doute un peu plus
tard aussi bonjour adrien hardy ou nous
ramener sur terre voilà que le
gouvernement legault qui dépose sa
première mise à jour économique
oui exactement ça se passe aujourd'hui
tous les détails seront connus vers
l'heure du midi et on doit s'attendre
mise à jour économique qui serait
résumée par de la prudence et des
dépenses on va tenter de trouver
l'équilibré entre les deux premières
mises à jour économique du ministre des
finances